et on débute avec la Nuit européenne des
musées elle aura lieu ce samedi à 13 mai
pour ça 19e édition dans les Yvelines
une vingtaine de musées châteaux vous
ouvrent leurs portes avec au programme
et des visites gratuites on va mettre le
focus et le curseur sur deux sites avec
Pierre marivottier bonsoir bon
bonsoir bonsoir Marie chargée du
développement touristique et de la
politique des publics pour le musée
départemental Maurice de nions on le
rappelle si tu es à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et à vos côtés
Frédéric debuch bonsoir vous êtes vous
conservateur le conservateur au musée de
la ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on
le rappelle aussi situé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux au sein du mumède
petit tour de table pour commencer
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous la
Nuit des Musées pourquoi c'est un
événement important qu'il faut défendre
Frédéric debuche
dans dans l'activité d'un musée
l'équivalent des journées du patrimoine
pour le patrimoine et pour nous c'est
une manière de donner une visibilité
importante sur sur notre lieu sur nos
activités sur nos propositions
d'exposition notamment voilà c'est un
grand moment de l'année l'occasion un
autre moment Pierre-Marie Gauthier
découvrir un musée là en nocturne
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous la
Nuit des Musées c'est une occasion de
vivre le musée autrement dans tous les
musées c'est une soirée où on va choisir
des mises en scène originales que ce
soit sur sur des ateliers ou sur des
visites ou sur de la danse c'est une
manière c'est un temps pour créer des
rencontres inattend
inattendu et qui vont permettre aussi de
renouveler les publics qu'on va tout
qu'on va toucher et c'est également un
temps de gratuité ce qui permet aussi de
toucher un public beaucoup plus large
très important de dire effectivement que
cet événement est gratuit autour de la
table Régine Catherine est-ce que vous
avez déjà visité un musée à l'occasion
de la Nuit des Musées la Nuit européenne
des musées
mais du coup je vais je vais recomm pour
cette année Catherine
deux petits musées qui vont ouvrir pour
la Nuit des Musées le musée de la
Grenouillère notamment donc oui oui on
l'a déjà fait et on participe beaucoup
de sites dans les unes c'est aussi vous
attendez beaucoup de monde sur sur ces
soirées en général Frédéric debuch c'est
fréquenté oui oui alors si on en juge
par la fréquentation l'année dernière il
y a eu beaucoup de monde plus de 1000
personnes musées de la ville voilà c'est
une belle une belle opération et
j'espère qu'on aura autant de monde
cette année c'est la même chose pour le
musée Maurice de Nice pour notre musée
c'est habituellement la deuxième journée
la plus importante de l'année après les
journées du patrimoine donc c'est
vraiment un temps majeur alors on va
parler du programme dans vos musées
respectifs et débuté par le musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
s'est associé à la médiathèque du canal
pour une soirée en apesanteur à quoi
faut-il s'attendre Frédéric lebuch oui
alors comme l'expliquer effectivement
Pierre Marie sont des des événements qui
permettent vous proposer une autre
lecture des collections du musée une
autre approche et on de capter aussi un
nouveau public un public familial public
local ou extérieur et cette année on
propose des activités et une
programmation en lien avec notre
exposition spéciale quand le la concasse
spatiale inspire le design
actuellement musée de la ville qui a été
inauguré en février et donc on a une
série de propositions autour de la
thématique de l'espace naturellement
pour coller à cette exposition
temporaire il y a aussi une semble alors
j'ai vu dans le programme on pourra
réveiller notre âme de Jedi qui
sommeille en nous il y aura une
initiation sabre laser
il y a des animations à côté de la
découverte des musées alors il y aura
beaucoup d'animations à la fois sur le
parvis devant le mymède et à l'intérieur
du alors du muet à la fois musée et
médiathèque puisqu'effectivement comme
on l'a rappelé nos collègues de la
médiathèque s'associent à cette à cette
soirée et donc voilà différents
événements enfin très très diversifié à
la fois du spectacle de rue avec
une association qui va présenter une
déambulation en ville et un spectacle
sur sur le parvis
des animations avec une association
lacia qui est une association pour la
création et l'innovation en action
culturelle qui a proposé à la fois des
simulations avec de la réalité de la
réalité virtuelle des simulations de vol
spatial ou d'une
d'une d'un moment de vie dans la navette
spatiale internationale ou alors des de
création de fresques collectives ou de
sculptures collective également en
réalité
virtuelle donc voilà des animations très
interactives ou faire à tous les publics
et puis vous l'avez rappelé
le sabre
[Musique]
en tout cas des animations parce que oui
des musées c'est l'occasion de
redécouvrir un autre moment les
collections des musées les expositions
quand il y en a en ce moment et aussi
proposer des animations et c'est une
soirée qu'on rappelle qui est gratuite
du côté du musée du Maurice Denis alors
vous proposez vous de multiples
animations entre ombres chinoises
croquis visite guidée c'est ça en
précisant aussi qu'il y a toujours une
exposition aussi sur sur le le site du
musée Maurice Denis oui et vu que c'est
une exposition qui approche de son terme
elle se termine le à 2 juillet c'est la
dernière occasion d'y entrer
gratuitement ainsi que de voir les
sculptures d'une artiste contemporaine
qui s'appelle Cécile rénale
et c'est vraiment sur sur la femme à la
fois
à la fois comme comme
sujet comme comme modèle mais
également comme artiste entre autres
dans les années 50 ou 7 carrière
d'artiste femme n'était pas pas
forcément aussi simple la médiation
qu'on va proposer pour cette soirée
c'est un peu une médiation à la carte on
aura 5 animateurs qui seront dans 5
espace différents avec avec chacun une
offre qui leur
ressemble pour les familles on a un
animateur qui vous proposera de créer
votre propre théâtre d'ombre on a une
autre plasticienne qui a fait énormément
de recherches sur les artistes femmes
méconnus de notre musée et le présentera
le fruit de ses recherches on pourra
également faire du des du des dessins
autour des statuts extérieurs
qui ont fait
l'objet d'un très important travail de
mise en lumière voilà et c'est des
statuts de Bourdelle qui est un artiste
vraiment immense de cette transition
entre le 19e et le 20/20e siècle
l'histoire du bâtiment les jardins aussi
du musée Maurice
seulement donc voilà toute cette partie
qui est autour du statuelle R2 à Bourdel
ça vous donne envie de tester le
programme le Jedi l'âme du Jedi pour
vous peut-être Régine c'est ce qui
m'intéresse le plus pour vous Catherine
Noël sur scène mais on peut aller aussi
dans d'autres endroits des Yvelines le
programme est alléchant on peut tout à
fait je vois qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses en effet à l'échange dans le coin
en tout cas merci à vous deux de d'en
avoir parlé et tous les renseignements à
retrouver bien sûr sur vos différents
sites internet on peut peut-être les
rappeler pour le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on trouve les
informations sur skype.fr directement
est-ce que y.fr pour le musée Maurice
Denis sur musée Maurice denis.fr alors
dans les Yvelines merci à vous d'autres
lieux culturels vous ouvrent leurs
portes voici une liste non exhaustive le
musée Lambinet à Versailles propose des
ateliers plastiques et des visites
guidées le musée d'archéologie national
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye s' illumine
jusqu'à minuit toujours à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'apotique royale
organise des visites commentées du côté
de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine des jeux de
lumière et des concerts animent le musée
de la batellerie et enfin de 20h à 23h
la maison de Raymond Devos à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse présente une
visite insolite retrouvée toutes les
informations bien sûr sur les différents
sites internet et des lieux culturels